[music]
I'm sorry, but for the time being,
thank you for putting your personality down.  I
apologize in advance for saying that, but
I'm really a little nervous, but
I'll do my best.
I'm
Sir
Topham Hatt and I'm the rapper in an electro swing rap group called Fake Type.  So, this time, I would like to
ask you to call me
Ao.  I'm playing music, so
I'm wondering how to do it historically until today's point
.
There was a site where you could post
raps, so I was doing raps on that site
, so I was about 20 years old.
I came out from my hometown, and I came out from my hometown to Tokyo a
little later, and
it was there
that we met for the first time, and we
hit it off and
became friends, so the timing of making music together wasn't great.
It wasn't there
, but the
songs that Dice and I performed together gave
us a really
good feeling
.
But when I was
about 24 years old,
there was a time when I thought I
should
quit music and work normally.
He
stopped me and told me that he wanted to make music with me, and I had
never done anything
like making money with that music.
You invited me to join you in the activity of earning money through music
. That's wonderful,
isn't it?
It's about money. It's the
first time I've learned how to make money with music since I started working on the body
.
However, after
four years, thirty-four years, and five years of activity,
the
Fake Type played
bass with the music called Electro Swing,
but the pace of releasing it was a bit
fast for both of us.  I was a little tired, I know how
you
feel.
In the meantime, I heard you
made some personal music or something
. You were doing a lot
of activities as a solo called Sir
Tophand, right
?  Right now, I
'm already using the
fake type as my main, isn't it?
I have a YouTube
channel, so
I'm a little curious as a YouTuber,
but
what kind of influence does YouTube have on my life and work
?
It's going
to be a music video, but it
's the main field for publishing it, so I think
it's a very
important place.
For
fans, almost all
fake music streams
are
on YouTube,
and
I feel that music videos are mainly watched on
YouTube, Spotify
, and so on.  I think there is, I see,
so I talked about it a little while ago,
but as
for my genre, it's a
slightly special genre
called
electro swing.  It's kind of like a mix of patterns,
but
what do you think about your own music
?  Even if you say
you want to be a pioneer of electro swing in Japan,
I don't think there are any Japanese people who are really doing electro swing as a main
activity.
I think I'm already used to being a pioneer of the Japanese select swing, but
no, I don't think it's okay.
I thought it had a very special feel to it, and the
juice has a slightly
old-fashioned atmosphere, but
I thought it would be great to mix it with rap,
and
I thought I couldn't hear it.
That's right.
I love the fact that I found a genre called electro swing, but first,
they taught me that, and I bought a band called
Mobitz, a Swedish band.
I was in a band called rap
, so
maybe I'm like a fake-type roots model
?
You've listened to it a lot, haven't you? Well
then, I
've already received it as an
inspiration.
I really
like Eminem, and I love him too
. On the
right is JD
. I often listen to famous rappers from overseas.
I've heard a lot
about it, isn't it wonderful?
Quite
possibly, because of that
swing style, kicks and
raps are fast, and
so on.
Maybe something,
how difficult is it
?  I want to make
it a bit different from other people,
so I definitely feel that way.
It's a
different story, but in
terms of content, the lyrics are
fast, but
if you listen to it, you'll hear a little social
message and so on.  Personally, I think so,
but I think
about the lyrics
properly,
how do you make them?
I think about it, but I also
tend to be a little cynical about
what I want to write.
And I
like that kind of thing, so
I think it's great to have that kind of stance on the
basics, is
n't it?
That's what I think, so
I'm happy.
Well, just a little while ago,
I felt something about animation, so I consulted with him about it.
I don't
remember much, but there
's a mutual friend of me and Dice named
Logico
, one of the PPs who made that MV
.  But it's better to
draw illustrations for us, so
when we were doing
that fake type, there was already talk of wanting to make an animated music video instead of a normal music video,
so it happened.  I
think it would be interesting
if it was a character that was part of a sampling sport,
or something like
that.
I don't know much about
honesty or the
audience, but
maybe
the character is more important than the real face.
When I first came here, I
didn't know how many months they would be showing their faces,
but
that's right.  No,
I just talked about animation,
but after that,
I would like to make a transition for One Piece in relation to Film Red.
I think so, but yes, I
made it from memory, but somehow,
from the outside, it's a
big brooch, but I heard that it's the
first time
I've had the opportunity to make a song with
Fimred.
I
'm sorry, but I was
really surprised that I couldn't believe
it.
When I heard
the story, but the story of this filmlet came
about a year or two ago,
Oda-sensei, the original author of One Piece, on
the page terminal behind the jump.
That's why I made a song called "Princess", and she put it on.
But I didn't think that the film
let would come so soon, so
I was really happy.
Well, from the time I was contacted for the first time
until the release date of the movie, it was
probably a long process and a
high tension major, but
what was the real
feeling?  There are a lot of them, but
we were in the position of providing that song, so I guess that's why I
love it.
I think it's a workflow of having people listen to it and check it out.
[Music] There
was no retention at all.
For the time being
, it's
like a melody,
asking for help  I had an image of fixing this and then fixing this
a little bit, but it wasn't at all.It's
amazing, all of those tracks are
amazing artists, but
maybe that's the end.
I've already
said the next thing, but
it feels like I saw it in Jump.
It's been a long time since I've been reading manga and
anime.
Most of the people
who have been reading it since it was released as
a
comic have been
reading it that way.
No,
I want to read something about
hearing loss all at once
.
It's
probably the first time I've seen it since I was in elementary school, and it's
been going on ever since
.
Isn't that
right? I'm really
looking forward to it,
isn't
there
?
Yes, from elementary school to high school and university
, I think it's interesting in terms of work
.
What did you think of that collaboration when
you were overseas
?  I
personally
listened to Mr. Ato's songs,
so I was really surprised to be able to work with such an amazing person, and I was very happy that he believed me.
Also, this song, Utakata Lalove,
contains a rather difficult rap part,
right? And that part is a
bit difficult because Mr. Ato isn't a rapper, so
I thought maybe there would be a retake.
I was thinking, but with that
first take,
everything's fine now.
By the
way, I think
you're a really wonderful
person.  That's wonderful
,
I don't think Mr. Hara ever used a car.  It's
just that I'm providing a song.It's a
bit like the coronavirus,
isn't it?
After all, it's a big project
, so I see. Well, in general,
fake-type songs are generally
a topic of
music,
so I think it's a movie that represents the charm and power of music.  But in general
, I think that music is a pretty important part of anime, isn't
it?
What do you think about the influence of music
? Well, I think that
anime music
culture is so big in Japan that it's called anime songs
.
I think it's a very important part in adding that atmosphere
, such as something very moving,
something sad or something fun, as one of the
productions
.  In the
future,
I'd like to see people who want to go to clubs with other anime or
something
.
After all,
I'm already making animations and music videos of my own,
but I
'd like to think that normal or popular animations are definitely similar
.  But somehow it's already a
new brooch project
I don't know.
Do you have a favorite
character
?  I feel
like
I want to eat Eneru gorogoro no nut
or thunder.  It's 3 o'clock, because he's good at cooking, isn't
he
Robin? A
zombie or a refugee is
Robin.
However, I think about Shanks, because he
was a fimlet, and he was a big part early, so I
didn't spoil much, but in
red,
personally
, what do you think about the chances in the future, good or bad?
I don't want to, but
if it's
evil,
I think there's a great development.  No
, it might be the most interesting story-wise
. I think it's a very important tent.
What is it about
One Piece?
Is there something you absolutely want
to
see?  It's kind of
like a timing capsule that understands history
Isn't that
kind of thing?  No
,
I'd like to see it in the future, but recently, the
fake type has
become more personal, and it's become popular
internationally,
isn't it
?  As
far as I can see, he made some great comments,
but that's
right. Someday
, I think it would be great if we could perform live in another country other than Japan, wouldn't
it be
wonderful?  Somewhere
in Japan, we're going to have a live show at the end of this year in December
.
Is there something you personally want to do as a fake type,
or something like a big Paula
bicycle project?
I want to do something like that
.  I'm doing
something like my own music or
my own SNS, and if I go to an audience that doesn't know me,
well, I'm doing something like an elect swing unit
called
Fake Type.  The two of us, the maker's colonels, are
making music.
I'm rapping and he's DJing
.
Since
this is
an interview for a film
called Filmnet, people all over the world are now able to watch it normally
.  I think it's a song that's
so distinctive that you can probably tell it's a fake type of music
, so I hope you'll pay attention to that as well
and watch the movie
.
thank you
thank you thank you thank you